thanks so much for coming everyone
coming out on early Saturday morning
this is very early in the morning for me
as you might imagine an astronomer I
like to stay up all night and then go to
bed when the Sun comes up but I'll try
and stay awake I've got some coffee here
I am just getting over a cold but I
think I can make it through if I lose
start to lose my voice maybe will pump
up the amplification so you can hear me
a little better so I am the director of
the observatory and planetarium here on
campus which the Astronomy you Donna me
apartment at Yale uses to teach
astronomy both in classes and also
taught school kids and also to the
general public and we open up the
observatory every Tuesday night to the
public so if you'd like to come visit us
up at the observatory come on up Tuesday
night it's right up the hill on Prospect
Street 355 prospect street and there's a
great website leitner observatory org
you go to this website you can see what
our planetarium shows are what the
events are that are coming up are you
can see if this guy is going to be clear
or not because if the skies are clear we
open up our telescopes for public
viewing we have wonderful telescopes up
there I'm going to talk all day or for
the next 40 40 minutes or so about how
telescopes work and what you can see
with telescopes so if you've never had
the chance to look through a telescope
definitely come up on Tuesday night when
it's when the sky is clear even if the
sky is not clear we have planetarium
shows at seven o'clock and eight o'clock
so this is our new haven observatory and
planetarium and place to go to learn
about science especially astronomy what
I'm going to tell you about today is
what you can see through a telescope how
a telescope works things like that this
image this this nebula up here is the
Orion Nebula it's a build big cloud of
gas which is hot because it's in the
process of making new stars and we
actually took this image using our
telescope at the observatory here in New
Haven so you can actually do astronomy
in New Haven even where you have lots of
light pollution and you can see some
really amazing things so who knows who
is the first person to use the telescope
does anyone know do you know do you know
who was the first person to use a
telescope no do you know Galileo exactly
and Galileo didn't invent the telescope
but he was the first person to use the
telescope to look at the sky and I
happen to have a replica of the gout the
telescope that Galileo use I'll talk
about how it works and you're welcome to
after the top come take a look at it
maybe we'll take it to the back of the
room and we'll put a nice image of the
moon or something on the screen and you
can do some indoor astronomy as we call
this you can see how the telescope works
okay um let's see how telescopes work so
what can you see through a telescope
well first of all I should just talk
about astronomers and telescopes and how
astronomers use telescopes this is
probably the way most people think about
astronomers using telescopes or maybe
something like this you know an
astronomer setting up a telescope on a
nice clear night looking through seeing
the stars maybe it's a really really big
telescope and he's looking through and
he's got a candle there and a little
sketch book and he's sketching what he
sees this is the way astronomers did
astronomy about a hundred years ago so
we don't do astronomy this way anymore
so this is the way what we call amateur
astronomers do astronomy these are
astronomers who are doing astronomy
because they love it because they just
love to go outside and look at the sky
using their eyeball looking through a
telescope finding planets and finding
nebulae and galaxies and there's kind of
a challenge of the hunt of finding new
things that are even further and further
away that's really really exciting but
it's a little bit different from the way
professional astronomers work today
professional astronomers almost never
look through telescopes it's kind of sad
professional astronomers are just people
to make a living doing astronomy so
that's the really the only difference
many of them love astronomy all of them
love astronomy or they wouldn't do it
but usually they're trying to understand
the physics of how a galaxy works or the
physics of how a planet formed or maybe
is there life on this planet they're
trying to figure out some science aspect
of that where as an amateur astronomer
is doing it for the love of
looking at the sky and seeing all these
amazing things learning as much as they
can how many of you are amateur
astronomers you don't have to have a
telescope to be an amateur astronomer
just if you like to look at the sky and
learn about astronomy you're an amateur
astronomer so as I said this is a way
most people think of astronomers these
days and unfortunately it's not really
true this one also isn't true this is
the way most people think people who
have read Harry Potter think this is
what astronomy is but unfortunately it's
a lot more mundane and boring rather
than sitting in front of telescopes all
night what astronomers mostly do is sit
in front of computers all day so we
write grant proposals and we maybe get
data from a telescope in Hawaii that's
an image of a galaxy that's really far
away so that's really exciting and we're
trying to learn something about the
galaxy how far away is it what is it
made of when did it form how is it
different from our galaxy we're trying
to figure out all those things on the
computer not at the telescope because we
took the we got the data from the
telescope the night before so we send
the computer we figure this out we write
a paper we send it to our colleagues
they say you're crazy that's not the way
that galaxies forum but I think it
formed this way and it's really it can
be really exciting when you have a
controversial new idea and you're trying
it out with other people but that's
really more what astronomy is like today
much less like this or like this I
myself I'm a radio astronomer so I don't
actually look through telescopes at all
when I'm doing my astronomy research I
use telescopes that measure radio waves
from other galaxies and from gas and
them in the Milky Way galaxy and so
forth so maybe some of you have seen the
movie contact it's a great movie with
Jodie Foster in it she actually
discovers aliens using a signal from an
alien civilization using a telescope in
New Mexico this is the telescope that I
used to do my my PhD research and I
still use it sometimes from my research
so it's a completely different kind of
astronomy and indeed astronomers are
very different they'd use lots of
different kinds of light to study the
universe not just the light that you can
see with your eye so there are some
x-ray astronomers and gamma-ray
astronomers and infrared astronomers and
radio strana murs and so forth and we're
all trying to figure
up this big question of how does the
universe work but some of us still love
doing amateur astronomy and love looking
through telescopes and that's one of the
great privileges that I have running the
observatory here in New Haven is that I
get to set up telescopes and go outside
and show people the night sky and shoot
people Saturn for the first time and
show people the moon and its really
really wonderful amateur astronomers
also sometimes they form clubs so they
can get together and have star parties
together where they go out all night
with their telescopes and show people
their telescopes there's a great amateur
astronomy club in New Haven it's called
the amateur of the Astronomical Society
of New Haven and they meet up at the
observatory on the last tuesday of the
month so if you'd like to meet other
amateur astronomers or learn more about
amateur astronomy you can find out about
them and they can set you up with a new
telescope they can show you how to use a
telescope that will invite you to the
star parties there's all sorts of
interesting amateur astronomy going on
here in New Haven ok I want to talk
about how telescopes work for a minute
and then tell you what you can actually
see through a telescope that's why i
call this talk the universe in your
hands because the telescope really is
like a spaceship if i use a telescope
that even if it only magnifies by 10
power 10 x that's not very high
magnification making things with 10
times bigger even if i use a telescope
that's only 10 x if i look at the moon
it's as if I'm 10 times closer to the
moon it's as if I've traveled ninety
percent of the distance from here to the
moon if I use a telescope that's a
hundred power which is pretty typical
most amateur telescopes you use like 50
to 200 x magnification and no more
there's no point using more if I use a
telescope with a hundred x magnification
and I look at the moon it's like I've
traveled 99% of the distance from here
to the moon I see the moon as it would
look if I were at that distance so who
is the first person to use telescopes
for astronomy someone said Galileo
that's exactly right it was 400 years
ago last year in 1609 the Galileo used
the telescope to look at the moon and he
made incredible new
discoveries this tends to be the case in
astronomy and any time you build a new
telescope and you think Oh what are we
going to look at well just go look at
everything because you'll find something
new meant no matter what you look at and
that was true for Galileo so he looked
at the moon and he saw craters and
mountains things that people had never
seen before he looked at Jupiter and he
saw moons orbiting Jupiter things that
people had never seen before even
thought possible so it's really amazing
the things that you discover when you
point a new telescope at the sky now i
should say Galileo did not invent the
telescope we're not really sure who
invented the telescope it's actually a
very very simple thing it really is just
two pieces of glass that are held in the
right place to give you the right
magnification we know that people long
before Galileo were using glass lenses
to magnify light and to change the
direction of light so for example here
is an image this is a painting from a
church in Italy and you see some monks
that are studying this is you know these
are the academics and the scholars of
this time period of the medieval time
period and one of these guys let's see
one of these things is not like the
other one of these things just doesn't
belong so one of these guys is actually
a little bit different and it's not just
he's wearing a funny hat let's see can
you see that guy right there what he's
doing he's wearing glasses actually this
is the first representation we have of
anyone using glasses to magnify what
they're looking at her to change what
they're looking at so we know that as
early as the 1300s people were making
glass into special shapes to do what we
call optics to change light to change
the magnification of light and improve
their vision here you can see that guy
these monks of course you know they're
sitting in there in their studies all
day copping out manuscripts their eyes
go bad really fast so this is a great
advantage to be able to seed more
clearly when you're doing this work so
what Galileo did was they took two of
these lenses that people have been using
before for various types of optics and
he held them it separated from each
other he had one lens that was a
magnifying
and another lens that was slightly
different that was the opposite of that
and if you hold them in just the right
place you end up seeing a very much
magnified image of whatever the object
is in the distance so really it's just
two pieces of glass so here is a
magnifying glass so simple magnifying
glass you can buy at an office store and
department store and what it actually
will do is focus light so that if I look
at the light from the projector or if I
look at the light from the lamps
overhead I can make a little image of
those lights I could even do it on my
hand here never try this with the Sun by
the way but it makes a little focused
bright image underneath the lens so what
Galileo did was say oh I'm going to look
at that image with another magnifier and
he invented the telescope so I'll pass
this around so you can try this out
yourself this is the lens in front so it
just hold out in front of your face this
is the magnifier that goes in front of
your eye this is in fact a real
telescope eyepiece this is not a real
telescope lens that's just a magnifying
glass but if you hold this up to your
eye everything looks blurry nothing's in
focus if you hold this lens in front
yeah I see you back there so try this
out hey go just pass it around the room
it'll make it all the way around by the
end of the talk so last year was the
400th anniversary of Galileo's first use
of the telescope for astronomy and so we
celebrated it as the international year
of astronomy and one of the things we
did at the planetarium was commissioned
an artist in Italy to make a telescope
very very similar to Galileo's so this
telescope I have in the front of the
room is made using the same materials
that Galileo might have used it's made
of wood and leather and very simple glue
now the lens though that's at the front
is much much better than the lens that
Galileo would have had the lens that
Galileo use would have been greenish and
it would have had bubbles in it you know
imagine like a an old wine bottle glass
Galileo didn't have access to really
high quality glass like we do today but
nevertheless it still gives you a pretty
good idea of what Galileo saw here is
actually two of Galileo's actual
telescopes that are on display on a
museum in Italy so if you go to Italy
you get a chance to see them now we were
very lucky last year these telescopes
went on tour and they were actually in
Philadelphia for a while so yet we had
the chance to examine them up close one
thing to notice about Galileo's
telescope is that the opening at the end
is very very small so the opening that
lets the light in is very very very
small so that meant that the images that
Galileo saw were very very dim
unfortunately compared to the telescopes
that we can use today but here's the
basic idea this is kind of a
physics.optics lied to show you exactly
how this work two pieces of glass that
have just the right shape the lens in
front astronomers call that an objective
and all it is supposed to do is focus
and gather light so you're looking at
something very faint it actually
concentrates the light beam so that it
looks brighter to your eye and that's
very important because when you look at
stars that are really far away you want
to see as much light as you can you want
to get all that light into your eyeball
then the second piece of glass back here
is just to magnify it so this is what
sends the light into your eyeball and
you can actually get a magnified image
of the star that's floating in front of
your face all telescopes are just like
this it's really very very simple just
two pieces of glass that are held in
just the right place so last year for
the international year of astronomy
there was a private organization that
tried to make a very cheap very simple
telescope that we could get into the
hands of lots of kids and teenagers and
college students and people who may have
never looked through a telescope before
but maybe you could get their own
telescope and so the design this
telescope called the Galileo scope and
it's very very simple the tube is made
of plastic you can take it apart you can
put it
gather you actually make your own lenses
you put your lenses together I can take
it apart and show you the objective so
this is the objective this is the lens
that actually gathers all that light and
makes the image in the front it's a much
much better lens than that magnifying
glass that makes a much sharper brighter
image than that magnifying glass so it's
actually a very nice little telescope we
gave a few of them away at the
planetarium and I think they're still
selling them at the Peabody Museum in
the gift shops if you go over to the
peabody museum gift shop you may be able
to pick one of these up you can also go
online if you go to Galus galileo scope
org you can still order them online and
they're really really nice I'll pass
this one or this one around to so you
can take a look at it this is a really
great first telescope it lets you see
all the things that Galileo saw 400
years ago only much better so what did
Galileo see 400 years ago what are the
things that Galileo saw with his
telescope well after Galileo spent about
a year looking at the sky with his
telescope he published a book it was
called siberius none see us in latin
which means the starry messenger in
english and he published his drawings of
the moon now before Galileo everyone
thought the moon was perfectly smooth it
was like an egg like the surface of an
egg perfectly smooth and Galileo saw no
there are shadows and it's a very rugged
shape especially where you go from night
on the moon today on the moon that edge
there where the sun is setting on the
moon you can see that it's just like
mountains on the earth where the top of
the mountain hits the sunlight first and
then the base of the mountain eventually
comes into the sunset you can see this
for yourself with a Galileo scope or any
small telescope if you come up to the
observatory on Tuesday night when the
moon's out you can definitely see this
yourself this is basically what it looks
like this is basically the same view
that you get from that little telescope
so you see all the craters and the
mountains very clearly here at the edge
of nine
and day on the moon something else that
Galileo did was he looked at the Milky
Way so people had noticed the Milky Way
before of course you look up at the sky
you see this band of light going across
the sky how many of you have seen the
Milky Way Oh most of you I'm so happy
you can't really see the Milky Way in
New Haven because of all the city lights
so I've never seen the Milky Way myself
in New Haven I think I saw it once in
branford when I was by the water and it
was pretty dark but if you want to get a
really good view of the Milky Way you
have to go away from the city lights
look up you'll see this band of light
going across the sky before Galileo no
one really knew what it was Galileo
pointed his telescope at the Milky Way
and he realized that oh it's made up of
stars it's just thousands and thousands
and thousands of faint stars that you
can't see they're not bright enough to
see separately with your eye but with
the telescope he could see oh it's just
a bunch of faint stars and that was a
very big discovery probably the thing
that Galileo is most famous for though
is finding the moons around jupiter so
here's jupiter has seen through a
telescope and then here are the four
moons that are named after Galileo the
Galilean moons does anyone know what
their names are anyone know what the
moons of Jupiter are you can just say
them if you know I 0 is 1 you ropa very
good Callisto yes there's one more
what's the ugh last one enemy yes very
good so I Oh Europa Callisto and
Ganymede they're very interesting places
they're actually more like the earth or
like the Earth's moon then they are like
Jupiter Jupiter is a big ball of gas so
it's very different from the earth but
I'll Europa and Callisto Ganymede
they're more like the earth and so we
think that there's the water we think
that there's an ocean underneath the ice
of Europa so if we look elsewhere in the
solar system for life the moons of
Jupiter are places we might go look and
see is there life elsewhere in the solar
system not just on the earth the big
thing that Galileo discovered was that
these moons go around Jupiter so here's
an actual part of this is part of a
drop this this is actually part of
Galileo's book and here's the first
drawing that he made in January of 1610
of Galileo and the moon's he said oh
look there are these two little stars
that are on one side and one that's on
the other side that's interesting but
what was amazing was that he looked
night after night after night he kept
looking at Jupiter and he noticed that
they moved around so a couple nights
later he saw Oh all three of them are on
one side that's interesting and he
watched night after night after night
and he could see them all orbiting
around Jupiter so that's an amazing
discovery because around the time of
Galileo everyone thought that everything
in the solar system orbits the earth so
that he saw these moons orbiting Jupiter
was really new and interesting Jupiter
looks really neat through a telescope
there's a lot you can see I purposefully
showed you an image here of gap of
Jupiter as seen through a telescope not
a spacecraft we now have amazing images
amazing photographs of Jupiter taken by
the galileo spacecraft and by other
spacecraft the Voyager spacecraft but
this is what Jupiter looks like through
a telescope at the observatory or
typical telescope you can see the cloud
bands on Jupiter and something that
Galileo noticed was that there's a spot
on Jupiter that seems to stay there all
the time this is a huge hurricane about
four times the size of the earth that's
been blowing for at least 400 years on
Jupiter Galileo also looked at Saturn
and you know what Saturn famous for the
rings of course if you look at Saturn
through a telescope even a telescope
here in New Haven where the sky isn't
very dark or very sharp you can still
clearly see the Rings and if it's a very
good night you might even see that
there's a gap in the Rings and you may
see some of the clouds on Saturn as well
Galileo looked at Saturn but his
telescope wasn't quite good enough to
see the Rings separately he thought that
Saturn had ears basically so here's
Galileo's drawing of Saturn he thought
maybe they were moons that were always
in the same place around Saturn so he
didn't quite discover the rings of
Saturn but he saw that there was
something funny
Saturn Saturn is one of my favorite
things to look at through a telescope
because it always looks really really
good even if the sky isn't very clear
Saturn is up really early in the morning
this time of year so if you want to see
Saturn you have to go out at like two
three a.m. in order to see it but
Jupiter is really well placed now if you
come up to the observatory on a Tuesday
night this fall I guarantee you'll get a
chance to see Jupiter I can just show
you actually here's the sky tonight this
is a planetarium program and here's the
sky tonight right at sunset and you see
Mars and Venus are setting in the West
right at sunset so if we go back a
little bit in time you see there's Venus
there's there's the Sun you see Saturn
is over towards the Sun so you have to
get up really early in the morning to
see it there's Venus Mars and now it's
dark so now it's about 8 30 and if we
look over to the east and southeast
there's Jupiter right there now it also
turns out that Uranus is very close to
Jupiter right now as well so you have
the chance of seeing Uranus through a
telescope this time of year as well so
come on up to the observatory on a
Tuesday night take a look at Jupiter
through our telescopes but if you get
your own telescope and it doesn't even
have to be a very big one just one of
these small Galileo scopes is certainly
good enough to see the moons of Jupiter
an amazing discovery you can make for
yourself is that the moons of Jupiter
are going around Jupiter that's what
Galileo saw one more really important
thing that Galileo saw was when he
looked at Venus he saw that Venus wasn't
a perfect ball it wasn't always
perfectly lit up it went through phases
just like the moon does so sometimes
venus is a crescent like the moon
sometimes it's half illuminated like the
moon sometimes it's almost fully
illuminated like the moon and what
Galileo realized was that this proved
that Venus goes round the Sun now that's
really obvious to us all the planets go
around the Sun but remember when Galileo
was alive for
years ago most people thought that Venus
goes around the earth and the sun goes
around the Earth and Jupiter goes around
you they thought that the earth was the
center of the solar system and
everything went round the earth Galileo
proved no Venus is clearly going around
the Sun because sometimes we see it as a
crescent sometimes we see it half
sometimes we see it full and that's all
that only works if you have Venus going
around the Sun so this is amazing proof
that the earth is not the center of the
universe all of these things you can see
for yourself with a very small telescope
you know you don't need a fancy
five-thousand-dollar $10,000 telescope
you can get a pair of binoculars that
have at least about 20 or 15
magnification or one of the Galileo
scopes and you can see this for yourself
okay well there are different kinds of
telescopes Galileo used invented a
telescope that used a lens so like this
we have a lens at the front and you have
a lens at the back but there are other
ways of making telescopes there are
other ways of gathering and focusing the
light here's one of these big telescopes
they're called refracting telescopes
because they have lenses this is the
biggest one that was ever made it you
see a person standing right there it's
in Wisconsin it's a few hours north of
Chicago in Wisconsin and you see how
long it is the lens at the front is
about a yard across it is that's the
lens at the front really really really
big lens when you start making lenses
this big the glass starts to sag in the
middle and all sorts of problems start
to happen you also get this problem with
the lens that the light will not focus
properly you'll actually see little
rainbows around the light this a very
very simple telescope that I passed
around with the magnifying glass when it
comes around to you may notice that when
you look through it everything is little
rainbows so lenses will actually do this
it'll turn things into little rainbows
well about a hundred years after Galileo
Isaac Newton came up with a new way of
making telescopes that used mirrors
instead of lens
so he realized that if you use a a
mirror instead of a lens to focus the
light you you solve a lot of problems
and you can make the mirror really
really really big so most of the new
telescopes that are built today use
mirrors instead of lenses so this is
another telescope that was built for the
year of astronomy last year it's made by
a company called celestron not very
expensive you can buy it online for
maybe fifty dollars or so and it's a
nice telescope for looking at the moon
and Jupiter and Saturn and so forth but
instead of having a lens at the front it
has a mirror at the back so it's a
completely different kind of optics this
type of telescope was invented by Isaac
Newton in 1600 1668 and it has a mirror
in the back and an opening at the front
and the light comes out sideways here
that's where you put your eyepiece and
you see the magnified image here's the
diagram of how that works so it's very
important that you have that little
mirror inside to send the light out
sideways otherwise you'd have to put
your eyeball in the middle of the of the
beam here and then you block the light
coming in so this little mirror right
here it does block some of the light but
it doesn't look very much of the light
and the light goes out sideways and you
look in at 90 degrees in order to see
what you're focusing on in order to see
the stars or in order to see Saturn so
this is a very simple little reflecting
telescope this is the kind of telescope
we use up at the observatory to do our
research projects and our student lab
projects and I'll pass this one around
as well but and look inside and see the
mirror and see the second mirror at the
front this one is a little bit more
sensitive to a donut crumbs so don't put
your fingers inside the the telescope
just look and see if you're in the very
back of the room you may be able to look
in the eyepiece and focus on what I'm
what I've got up at the screen if you're
in the front you may be too close it
probably won't focus the way we focus
the telescope is by turning this knob
which makes the eyepiece go further in
and out and that changes where you're
focused
these telescopes are called newtonian
telescopes after Isaac Newton and these
are very popular telescopes with amateur
astronomers because you can get a
telescope with a really big mirror for
not very much money for in terms of how
much you pay for it you get a lot of
light-gathering power in fact sometimes
astronomers call these big telescopes
with mirrors they call them light
buckets because they're big enough that
you get a huge amount of light coming
into your telescope here's an even
bigger one that amateur astronomers use
here's an even bigger one this is a
research telescope this is the Wisconsin
Indiana Yale telescope which is in
Arizona so this is one of the telescopes
that we use for research at Yale for
astronomy research at Yale it's mirror
is three and a half meters across so
it's actually a very very big mirror
back here in the back that mirror that's
going around is only about 70
millimeters or so across it's a much
much smaller telescope you want your
telescope to have as big a mirror as
possible because that's how you're going
to see the faintest most distant objects
so the bigger the mirror the more light
you're going to intercept the more light
you're going to focus and the fainter
you can see that's really really
important in fact that's the most
important thing about a telescope is how
big is what we call the aperture how big
is the lens or how big is the mirror
right Galileo's telescope you can see as
an aperture has a lens that's only about
an inch across so he couldn't see very
faint objects he could see the moon he
could see Jupiter he could kind of see
Saturn but he wasn't going to see other
galaxies he wasn't going to see nebulae
those are much to think you need a
bigger telescope in order to see these
things so when you go to shop for a
telescope if you're thinking about
buying a new telescope sometimes they'll
say oh this telescope magnifies a
thousand times or ten thousand times or
some enormous huge number well you don't
care about that you don't care at all
any telescope can magnify by any amount
you just have to change the eyepiece
what matters is how big is the mirror or
how big is the lens the bigger the lens
the bigger the mirror the fainter you'll
be able
to see the objects that you'll be able
to see that's why professional
telescopes we use for research are so
big we're looking at galaxies and
quasars and the edge of the universe
really far away we need really really
big telescopes the biggest telescopes we
actually put up on mountains far away
from cities so we have the darkest skies
and the sharpest images so this
telescope right here is the Gemini
telescope it's in Hawaii on top of Mauna
Kea in Hawaii you can go visit it it's
actually paid for by you if you pay
taxes you pay for it so it's a
nationally funded instrument it's not
some super rich guy uses it for his own
pleasure or whatever it's not
universally you run only it's paid for
by the National Science Foundation and
the US taxpayers and anyone can put in a
proposal to use it so if you have an
idea for what you'd like to do with this
telescope write out a proposal to the
National Science Foundation and send it
in and they'll consider whether or not
you could think you can use their
telescope you have a really good idea
they might give you time here's what it
looks like it's a really really big
telescope the mirror is 27 feet across
there you see the mirror right there and
it's hard to compare you know it look
this could just be a model a toy model
but there's a person there are two
people standing right there so there you
can see the size of that mirror all the
way across compare that with a little 70
millimeter telescope as I passed around
this is a much much much more sensitive
telescope okay now I just said that we
put these telescopes on mountains far
away from cities and a big part of the
reason why we do that is because of
something called light pollution so if
you build this big Observatory that
you're going to use to study the
universe you want to get the sharpest
image as you can and see the faintest
objects that you can so you don't want
to have city lights near your telescope
that make it hard to see now we have a
lot of problem with this in New Haven
here's kind of the New Haven skyline and
you can see all these lights at Yale
University and in the city and so forth
and on the one hand we definitely want
to have lights so that it's safe to walk
around at night and so you can see where
you're going and so
fourth but on the other hand it really
hurts what we can see in astronomy so
here are two pictures of the Milky Way
it's a little bit easier to see over
here you see the Milky Way right there
there's a house here's the house with
all of its lights turned on and the
light pollution makes the Milky Way go
away completely so when we can limit the
amount of light pollution if we can do
it without with still making it safe
then we want to do that in fact it's
kind of a way of saving energy you know
we're all worried now about greenhouse
gases and global warming and pollution
going into the atmosphere and so forth
and we want to conserve energy as much
as we can and in fact light pollution is
a big waste of energy all this light
just goes up into the sky and it makes
it worse for astronomy and it just
wastes a lot of energy you see we're
really really bad here on the East Coast
back over here in the mountain states
they have a little bit darker but we
have a huge amount of light pollution
over here especially if you zoom in here
on New England you can see well New
Haven is not in the worst place for
astronomy that might be in New York but
it's pretty bad if you really want to
see the Milky Way and see a dark sky you
kind of have to go up into Vermont or
New Hampshire now we do have an
observatory at Bethany observatory and
near bethany connecticut have any of you
been there before or heard of it before
yeah the amateur society the amateur
astronomy group in New Haven sometimes
they have star parties and classes and
things but there is an observatory in
Bethany where it's a little bit darker a
little bit better for astronomy but we
have it really bad in New Haven now what
can we do to make things better well a
lot of the lights around campus at Yale
or in the city they don't they don't try
and make the light come down to where
you're looking the light just goes up
into the sky so if you have a light
fixture like this the lights just going
up into the sky and lighting up the
astronauts and they don't really care
they don't really want to seal that
light here's another example of really
bad wasted energy wasted light pollution
you know some billboard that's vacant
for now and they never bother to turn
off the lights light up the billboard so
we're advertising blank space I guess
this is like an advertisement for his
den Buddhism or something I don't know
just think of that all of that energy
being wasted so if we install lights
that are shielded so that the light
comes down to what you're looking at
instead of going up into the sky it'll
be much much better for astronomy so
these lights that are shielded on the
top makes it easier to see the sky and
it saves a lot of energy they seem to be
better at this in Europe this is an
image of a highway in England and you
can see the lights are shining down onto
the highway it's kind of a foggy night
so you can see the cone of light coming
down and there's really not much light
going up into the sky so we need to get
better at this too so that we have
better astronomy and save energy as well
okay well the last thing that I want to
talk about is things that you can see
through a telescope that Galileo didn't
see so you do need a little bit of a
bigger telescope in order to see these
things but again if you come up to our
Observatory on a Tuesday night you can
see some of these things through our
telescopes so even where we have light
pollution in New Haven something we like
to look at our double stars these are
stars which are orbiting around each
other of course the Sun isn't a double
star we just have one star in our solar
system but some star systems have two
stars or even more stars orbiting around
each other and this is one of my
favorite double stars it's called
Albireo it's in the constellation of
Cygnus and it's two stars next to each
other that are different colors you
don't think usually if stars as having
really bright colors you look up at the
sky and you think oh the stars are so
pretty but they're basically white but
if you magnify a star and collect a lot
of light to look at it then you can see
oh no it does have a kind of a bluish
color or a little bit of a reddish color
or yellowish color or something like
that and stars do really have colors and
you can see that through a telescope
it's really very striking with these two
stars because of their so bright and the
right next to each other now why do the
stars have different colors why should
stars have different colors does anyone
know you know there might be different
gases but they're all made of hydrogen
almost all stars are made of hydrogen
what else how hot it is that's exactly
right so which star do you think is
hotter this one or this one the blue one
are the red one which one do you think
is hotter
you think yellow one is hotter and it
makes that might make sense the blue and
so how many people think the blue and
hotter how many people think they're red
one is hotter all few people okay well
if you heat something up and it glows
because it's hot first it glows kind of
red hot and then kind of yellow hot and
then maybe white hot and then if you can
get it really really hot it might start
to glow bluish hot so actually that's
right something that's glowing because
it's hot it will tend to glow bluish if
it's really really really hot like a
really hot star and if it's not so hot
at my glow reddish now red-hot is still
hot but red hot is not as hot as blue
hot you know so astronomers are always
confused we go to the sink and we want
hot water and there's a blue faucet and
a red faucet and we turn the blue faucet
and cold water comes out that doesn't
make any sense yeah this star is hotter
much much hotter a blue flame is hotter
than a red flame so this star is much
much hotter than that stuff when we look
at star clusters with our telescopes
sometimes we see colors and that's
because they're different temperatures
these are all very young massive stars
that are really really hot they have
kind of a bluish tinge now they're not
they're not bright blue they're not sky
blue it's kind of blue-white it's kind
of like easter egg colors you know
pastel blue and this one's kind of
yellowish so these blue stars are much
much hotter than that star right there
which is a red giant star here's another
double star we'd like to look at our at
our observatory this is my second
favorite double star which is actually a
quadruple star so if you look at it with
your eye you see oh look at that pretty
star it's just one star the star has the
name epsilon Leroy you zoom in with a
telescope and you say oh wait no it's
two stars they're orbiting around each
other two stars and then you zoom in
even more and you see all know it's four
stars it's two pairs of stars these
stars are doing a dose you do around
each other and these stars are doing a
dosti go around each other and then each
pair is going around each other around
their common center of mass so they're
doing this complicated square dance
around each other which is really cool
sometimes we look at our at these star
clusters with our telescopes so you
would be able to see this with a small
telescope as well star clusters are
really really beautiful in a small
telescope these are groups of stars that
have fairly recently formed from gas in
the Milky Way and they're all at about
the same distance so they're all in its
nice little tight cluster the Sun used
to be in one of these clusters too but
over time we drifted away here's another
one this one is an older denser star
cluster a lot of these objects I put the
name of these objects you can see this
is M 11 the wild duck cluster this is n
13 the Hercules cluster and so forth you
see a lot of them have em and then a
number these are named after astronomer
charles messier who was a french
astronomer who wanted to become famous
and how do astronomers become famous
well these days i guess you have to win
the Nobel Prize or you have to have a TV
show like Carl Sagan or something like
that there aren't that many famous
astronomer is right now but in these
days back then if you wanted to become
famous what you had to do was discover a
comet so Charles Messier really wanted
to discover a comet and he would go out
every night to his observatory with a
six inch telescope and he'd scan the sky
is looking for comments and comets are
basically little fuzzy things in the sky
and night after night they move relative
to the stars so he'd scan the sky and
heat co a fuzzy thing and he'd write it
down you go back the next night sent oh
it's still there write it down oh it's
still there I guess it's not a comet
it's not moving around relative to the
stars because the Comets are orbiting
the Sun just like the planets are so
Charles Messier wrote down a list of
fuzzy things in the sky that are not
comments and now we call them the
Messier objects and they're mostly star
clusters and nebulae and galaxies and
things like that so m13 was the 13th
object that Messier wrote down in his
list that wasn't a comet well he did
actually find comets he was a diligent
astronomer he found six comets in his
lifetime but we don't remember him for
that now he's not famous for the
comments he's famous for these things
that he wrote down that aren't comments
but all of these objects are really nice
to look at through a small telescope
they're all very pretty now through a
really small telescope like the Galileo
scope if you look at a nebula it might
just look like a little fuzzy little
fuzzy ball you need a slightly bigger
telescope to see some detail but for
example here's a nebula called the
dumbbell nebula and again this is an
image from our telescope up at the
lightener observatory you can see the
colors you can see this big fuzzy ball
this is the shell of a star that's died
so this is what the Sun is going to look
like in about six billion years when the
core of the Sun collapses the outer
layers expand to make a big nebula this
is what it's going to look like here's
another one this is m20 the trifid
nebula this is a place where stars are
forming so you get gas clouds in places
where new stars are forming or where
stars are dying because stars are made
of gas of course stars will attract in
gas on there by their gravity the star
will live for billions of years maybe
and then it will die and push the gas
back out and it will eventually make new
stars so stars recycle their very good
that way here's another one this is the
Eagle Nebula a little bitty to you to
see up on that screen this is one of my
favorite nebulae this is called the ring
nebula looks just like what it's called
fortunately this is another one of these
nebulae where the star has died the core
of the star has collapsed to make this
thing called a white dwarf there it is
right there the white board the outer
layers have expanded off to make the
shell of gas which is very hot and it's
expanding and cooling and maybe someday
in the future it's going to make this
gas will make a new star sometime in the
future in a few billion years now
whenever we have a public night up at
the observatory someone will say oh I
want to look at a galaxy let's look at a
galaxy this is the Andromeda galaxy
which is the closest galaxies to us
galaxies are whole islands of stars that
are their own separate thing every star
that you see here in the sky in this
image is in our galaxy and this the
Andromeda galaxy is in the background
it's two million light years away so its
many many many times further away than
these stars that you can see in the four
well galaxies are so far away that
they're very dim they're very hard to
see especially if you have a sky that's
kind of bright from light pollution so I
have to tell people galaxies don't look
like this in a small telescope so you go
and you shop for a telescope at Walmart
or Target or at an optic store our
camera store whatever or online or
whatever and the box will have pictures
like this on the box and I can't tell
you I shudder to think at the number of
people who have been scared away from
astronomy because they look at this on
the box and they get their telescope out
and they pointed at the sky and they
don't see this right this is a this is
an image which was taken by a big
telescope with a long exposure with a
digital camera and we can make pictures
like this using our telescope but it
takes a lot of work you just can't look
through the telescope and see this this
is what galaxies look like through a
telescope this is a sketch someone did
of the Andromeda galaxy through a
telescope you tend to see a little fuzzy
ball of light and you might see a little
bit of light from the disk of the galaxy
kind of extending it out and if the
galaxy has satellite galaxies you may
see those as well it's a very subtle
experience it's not as exciting as
seeing the moon or Saturn or Jupiter
through a telescope those are the things
i recommend you look at first Saturn the
things that Galileo looked at that look
amazing the moon gala Jupiter Saturn and
so forth star clusters double stars once
you get more advanced than it is very
rewarding to go hunt down these galaxies
and look at them with your eye and maybe
even take a picture it's not that hard
to take pictures of things through the
telescope so here's another famous
galaxy the Whirlpool Galaxy and it just
looks like a fuzzy thing you might be
able to see a little bit of a spiral
arms when you look at it through an
eyepiece so don't gets don't get your
hopes up about looking at galaxy okay
actually one last thing that I do want
to talk about before I finish up today
and that's how professional astronomers
use telescopes as well so we don't use
the small telescopes to do our research
because we need really really big
telescopes to get to see the faintest
objects but we also want to have a
really sharp image of what we're looking
at
and unfortunately we're looking through
the atmosphere which is very turbulent
and has a lot of them has a lot of
storms and wind and so forth and it
makes the images not very sharp so a new
technique that astronomers are using
with telescopes is something called
adaptive optics we can shoot a laser
beam up into the sky and measure how the
atmosphere is twinkling and then we can
change our telescope to remove the
twinkling so whereas with our telescope
you might see just a blob of light when
you turn on the laser you see oh there
are actually two stars there that are
right next to each other you get a much
much sharper view so for example the
Keck telescope in Hawaii can look at
Uranus and Neptune and make a kind of a
blurry image this is Uranus did you know
Uranus has rings Uranus has where all
the play all the outer planets have
rings Jupiter Saturn Uranus and Neptune
they all have rings but Saturn's are
coated with ice so they're very shiny
you can see them very easily in a much
bigger telescope to see the rings of
Uranus but here's the blurry view and
then here's the sharp view and here's
the blurry view of Uranus and then
here's the sharp view so that lets us
see a lot more than we be able to see
just looking through the atmosphere this
is why the hubble space telescope images
are so great sometimes people think
Hubble's a great telescope because it's
closer to galaxies and the planets and
the nebulae well it's only about 100
miles up maybe 200 miles up above the
Earth's surface that's not very close
much closer compared to millions of
light-years right but what Hubble does
is it gets above the sea of the
atmosphere above the turbulent twinkling
of the atmosphere so that gives us much
much much sharper images for example
this is an image of a nebula called the
Eagle Nebula you see it a little bit
better up there see that red light that
glowing red light there and then here's
a star cluster right next to it it's the
Eagle Nebula if i zoom in on part of it
you see there's kind of a dust cloud
right there and a dust cloud right there
and you see those two stars right there
now this is what it looks like from New
Haven this is what it looks like from
the Hubble Space Telescope right it's
the same part of the sky these two let's
start right there and those that start
right there those are the same as that
star in That star or that star in That
star and now you can see all of these
little gas clouds all these little dust
clouds and all these new
little stars that are forming in this
cloud of gas so it tells us so much more
about what's going on if we have a much
much sharper view I showed you the ring
nebula before here's our view from New
Haven it's very pretty it's very
beautiful very colorful if we look at it
with ample space telescope we see so
much more detail we see all these little
clouds of gas and dust and we can see
the star in the middle really sharply so
that's really really important I also
mentioned that it's really important for
us to use other types of light so
infrared light it's really important for
us to study galaxies and nebulae and so
forth using infrared telescopes if we
can so here are some astronomers you see
their telescope over there and they're
using an infrared camera they're taking
just a group photo right now you can see
what these people look like an infrared
light we think of it as heat light
because with something that's warm will
emit infrared radiation but stars and
galaxies will also emit infrared light
you have to put a telescope in space in
order to see it but for example here's
an image of the Whirlpool Galaxy i
showed you before they're all the stars
and now here's all the warm gas and dust
that's emitting infrared radiation it's
kind of like night vision goggles we can
see all of this stuff that we couldn't
see before with the infrared telescope
okay um actually I think I will finish
up there my last two slides I just want
to show you if you're interested in
buying a telescope or thinking about
buying a telescope a really great
telescope to start with is actually just
a pair of binoculars if you get at least
15 power you'll be able to see a lot of
the things Galileo saw them the the
craters on the moon and the moons of
Jupiter and so forth you won't be able
to see the nebulae as sharply as with a
telescope but they're very easy to use
they're not very expensive you can go
and sit out on a lawn chair and sit back
and just scan this guy back and forth in
fact people today who look for comments
sometimes they'll just use really big
binoculars and they'll just scan the sky
back and forth so these are binoculars
made for astronomy the front of the the
aperture the lens size is 70 millimeters
in the magnification is 15 power and
they're really really nice for getting
into astronomy learning where these star
clusters are learning the constellations
it's really really nice when you become
a little more advanced
a good telescope to start with is one of
these Newtonian telescopes this is one
made by a company called Orion and there
are about two hundred dollars or so has
a six inch diameter mirror and they're
really really nice for looking at star
clusters and double stars and the moon
and so forth and it's a great way to get
started okay well I hope you enjoyed
that me talking about telescopes if
you'd like to check out my gal Galileo
replica telescope please feel free to
come on down and have a great day